[Music]
I'm on a one-day break from touring with
Jordan Peterson and joining me in studio
today is a free-speech lawyer and the
director of the individual rights
defense program at the foundation for
individual rights in education
aka fire ah Rico and welcome to the
Reuben report thanks for having me
that was a wordy intro a lot of freedom
stuff in there and that's all the stuff
that I like so I'm looking forward to
this say so you guys fire as an
organization is one of the the few
bastions of sanity these days like when
I see what you guys are tweeting about
and consistently defending the
principles of free speech and free
expression and open inquiry I'm always
like ah there are some good guys left so
first can you just tell me a little bit
about the organization why you guys got
started how you personally got involved
well we got started in 1999 with a
professor at Penn and a civil liberties
lawyer in Philadelphia who we're you
know they both decided that there were
there was a problem there was an
epidemic at our colleges and
universities of the core individual
rights that that make up you know our
our Constitution if you will as
individuals as people as citizens of the
United States
we're being respected on campuses across
the country back in 99 99 yeah that's
interesting because a lot of people say
this is just the totally recent
phenomenon well I think you know a lot
of it the there is the political
correctness movement of 80s and 90s a
little bit you know that might have had
something to do with it but then this
has been a problem since the Free Speech
Movement back at Berkeley you know long
before even the 80s or 90s you know
censorship is an age-old problem it
predates the United States of America
really and as Alan and Harvey you know
went about creating fire and they
decided to locate it and like located in
Philadelphia which is you know the
birthplace of our nation they really got
an outpouring of people saying hey this
happened to me too and they said well
this is you know this is a problem this
is an epidemic we need to fix
and fire I was born or lit if you will
and over the years I getting close to 20
now crazy enough that has actually just
gone up every year more and more people
reach out to fire for help you know when
I got to fire for the second time
actually was a legal fellow of fire
after I graduated from law school before
I started in private practice but when I
came back in 2013
getting several hundred K submissions a
year and now we're getting damn near
close to a thousand a year and that's
just the stuff that we hear about can
only imagine how much other stuff is
going on around the country for people
who don't know that we're out there to
help them or you know people who perhaps
go about it themselves it's it's crazy
to think about how much is going on yeah
so I want to talk about some of those
cases and some of the specific work that
you're doing
but foundation for individual rights in
education I am a believer right now
partly because of Kanye West and because
of a lot of people online right now that
the individual is making a comeback that
the idea of the individual verse the
collective is actually making a comeback
do you have any idea when they came up
with the name for fire why it was so
important to put the individual front
and center well I think it's you know
and I'm speaking you know out of some
level of ignorance because I haven't
actually discussed this with either of
them personally but you know if I had to
guess it's it's because the the
individual qualities the freedom of
conscious the freedom of speech the
things that allow us to participate in
society we don't get to the collective
unless we have the individuals one is
necessary to have the other because what
is a collective other than a group of
individuals and consensus is a bunch of
individual opinions that throughout the
process of winnowing and debating
different good ideas and bad ideas we
reach a common understanding we reach a
you know a norm for society and that's
how that's why free speech particularly
is so important
that's how we get to the optimal
resolution the optimal conclusions
that's how we reach these communal
positions is only through our own
personal expressions of what we believe
which exposes us to criticism or
agreement or just flat-out discussion
with other people so how do you think
the ideas of the collective took root so
much at college campus then well I think
there's the give-and-take in society at
large that we really go through every
once in a while in terms of thinking
about things as individualistic and then
worrying about broader concerns of the
community and that's not altogether a
bad thing and I think the college campus
and it's always been this way it's a
microcosm of what we're experiencing in
the broader society and I think that's
another reason why it's so important to
protect individual rights on college
campuses because where they fall on
college campuses they're almost
certainly sure to fall in society writ
large yeah so that actually we discussed
this briefly right before the cameras
turned on that's my concern about this
when people will say oh you know there
isn't a free speech issue on college
campuses and even though I keep going to
college campuses and it's very clear to
me that there is a free speech problem
there but it's not what's gonna happen
it's not just these screaming kids right
now it's not that it's that these are
the people that are going to be in
leadership positions 5 10 15 years in
the future and further than that
obviously and if those ideas take root
because they were able to silence us
once they are the lawmakers once they're
in charge of public policy they're not
going to be too kind to the people who
they were silencing way back when right
yeah I mean that's really one of the key
problems and it's not even just if they
get elected to power even if they aren't
elected and they don't rise to power and
they can't impose these views on other
people these are future citizens even if
they're not necessarily future leaders
and then discourse of the nation if that
is the the prevalent feeling in society
is going to suffer tremendously as a
result if even if they're not in
Congress or in the state legislatures if
50 percent
the country's population thinks that we
shouldn't be talking about certain
things we're not going to talk about
these things and it's going to be
societally imposed if nothing else and I
think that's incredibly damaging to just
about every aspect of our life as a
country yeah it's so interesting to me
because I know used you read about this
but I was at the University of New
Hampshire a couple weeks ago and you
know first we were supposed to give a
speech on campus then about two hours
before they announced that they couldn't
secure the room that they felt there
were too many threats so they were about
200 or 250 people supposed to be in the
room they moved us to the hockey rink
which seats 7,500 people so I stood in
front of a little you know backdrop and
I talked to about 200 people it was
about 150 people that were there to
listen and be respectful and all that
stuff and then they were about probably
about 50 protestors roughly those are
the rough numbers but the desire just to
shout down to use noisemakers to scream
to chant like robots they love robotic
chants all of these things and I kept
saying to them guys do you have any
direct questions is there something that
I've said that you disagree with or is
there something you directly like to ask
me and time and time again the answer
was no and I don't know how you break
them out of that other than keep having
these conversations and hope that the
refugees make it to us and that's a
common problem I think it really comes
down to ideological purity that people
are after the idea that if I disagree
with you on something whether small or
even fundamental if I disagree disagree
with you on that one thing that means
nothing that you have to say could
possibly be of value to me and that is
completely false then you couldn't be
farther from the truth
we can learn so much from the people we
disagree with the most even if I
disagreed with you on absolutely
everything it would still be incredibly
valuable for me to talk to you if only
because that helps me sharpen and really
understand why I believe what I believe
in and people really discount the
importance of understanding why you
believe something yeah so the argument
that I've been making for a while is
that and I do think right now at least
in 2018 this is more of a problem on the
left
but they've only ideas in the narrative
and the college campus discussion and
academia and media and all that they've
owned that for so long that the reason
these kids end up be or these students
end up being so hysterical is because
they never hear counter ideas so then
you get a pretty moderate guy who's
arguing about liberty and freedom for
everybody and live and let live and that
actually offends them because they never
hear anything outside of what they're
being taught that goes to the academic
part I think mostly well I think we're
doing a really crappy job of educating
students before they get to college
about why free speech and our other
rights are important civics education is
clearly in the toilet right now yeah
and it's bizarre to me I grew up in
Skokie Illinois one of the sites one of
the most famous free speech cases you
know in recent history
yeah can you lay it out for those that
don't know this the story in the 70s the
American the American Socialist Party
that nationalist party the Illinois
Nazis if you'd ask the Blues Brothers
yeah wanted to march through Skokie
Illinois which outside of New York had
the largest concentration of Holocaust
survivors in the United States and
Skokie tried to stop them and they sued
with the aid of the American Civil
Liberties Union of Illinois and it went
too well both the Supreme Court of
Illinois and the Supreme Court of the
United States and the Nazis had the
right to march and and the courts held
so and there were threats of violence
and disruption and all you know people
out crying as to how this could be
allowed but ultimately the Nazis had the
First Amendment right to march through
Skokie and I grew up learning about that
case from a very young age I can't tell
you how many times I saw the movie they
made about it yeah and it really it got
me thinking at a young age about why
this is important how I think about it
and I can't tell you that as a young
child I completely agree that the Nazi
should have a right to march you know I
when I was that young a part of me
didn't grasp the overarching fundamental
importance of free speech but I was
thinking about it
yes and I got there and I get the
feeling that some
we're not doing enough to make our
students think about why it's important
yeah it's such an important case and I'm
glad you mentioned it because it goes
really to the heart of this that the
people that lived in Skokie as you said
the second largest amount of Holocaust
survivors in the country these people
literally survived the genocide probably
virtually all of them lost some of them
probably lost all of their family
members and friends and all of that and
yet I would sit here as someone that
lost Holocaust survivors on both sides
of my family and tell you it was the
right decision you can't let the the
Nazis or the white supremacist whatever
they're you can't let them start
ransacking property you can't let them
start killing people are harming people
but letting letting them march that's
the exchange of free speech and it's
kind of shitty but you got to defend it
when it's hard to defend you that's
defined it when it's hard to defend
because otherwise there's it's not going
to be around to defend when it's easy to
defend you know once you can start
creating exceptions and encroaching
there's no end to it and you know we've
kind of seemed even in other countries
that once the the encroachments start
it's always well we make that exception
and just this one other small exception
and then there's inevitably another one
and another one and all four perhaps
even you know good reasons in terms of
you know ideals and and the goals are
laudable perhaps I say at every show the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions getting tired of saying me
both yeah but you know it's really
practically speaking it's inevitable
yeah how much of this is just a
confusion as to what the First Amendment
is that's also what I've started to
realize because when I've gone on
college campuses and the protesters are
there and I always say it I welcome
peaceful protests I completely welcome I
welcome the exchange of ideas the
questions all of that but when when
they're screaming about certain things I
think there's just a disconnect as to
what I think to legal things I think
what the First Amendment is and what
hate speech is is or isn't so can you
talk about that a little bit yeah I if I
had to have to hear one more person
whether it be student
Internet comment or even journalists or
faculty numbers sometimes say hate
speech is not free speech I'm gonna lose
it okay so let's do it let's do that one
first cuz I really I mean this will be
maybe what we promo for this episode but
I really want people to understand this
why is hate speech free speech well on a
legal level hate speech is free speech
because the First Amendment and the
courts have said nothing about freeze or
hate speech being unprotected by the
First Amendment speech is protected by
the First Amendment unless it falls
under one of the very few existing
categories of unprotected speech yeah
what are what are those categories
there's incitement to imminent lawless
action and these all have very high bars
true threats and intimidation you can be
sued for libel or slander defamation as
they're known some states I think
actually still have criminal statutes on
the book but books but they're rarely
enforced love fraud obscenity which
people often confuse with mere profanity
or lewdness but they are not the same
thing by any stretch of the imagination
what's the difference on those two well
profanity and lewdness are generally
protected by the First Amendment
obscenity is a very high bar it's a
speech that has to be our expression I
should say more broadly than just speech
that has to appeal to the prurient
interest which is an inordinate
fascination with sex describe or depict
sex in a patently offensive way and have
no social political literary or artistic
value whatsoever and to get down in the
in the mud he ever heard of crush videos
I feel like I have but I'm honestly not
sure what that is they are videos of
women wearing stilettos crushing small
animals like hamsters and gerbils to
death and people apparently get off on
that yeah I don't intend to understand
it even that is not wholly unprotected
by the obscenity exception to the First
Amendment that that's a particularly
interesting case I suppose because the
idea of it talking about it seems like I
would have no problem with that but the
action itself probably there's
legal reasons right like killing and
killing animals there's some law I guess
if Charlie state law right but if you
have this pornography you can call it
that I just have a hard time getting it
yeah if you have it in you to possess it
or like unit you can't be prosecuted for
for possessing that obscene material
it's an interesting distinction that the
Act is the crime or the act is what is
illegal not the depiction depiction or
is it disseminating of the information
or that sort of thing right child
pornography obviously not protected by
the First Amendment yeah you know but
there's some others the one additional
wrinkle of the fighting words doctrine
although there's a considerable doubt
that it remains a viable exception to
the First Amendment but it really gets
brought up a lot in the hate speech
debate to the extent it still exists
it's limited to face-to-face
interactions where say I say something
to you that is so insanely abusive that
you are likely to punch me in the face
without thinking twice about it instead
of taking a deep breath and either
ignoring me or coming back at me and
there's reasons why it's fallen into
disuse and it's worthwhile to note that
the Supreme Court hasn't upheld a
fighting words conviction since the case
in the 40s when it created the fighting
which is how far it's fallen into disuse
it incentivizes punching people in the
face right it creates an easy way to
censor the people that you disagree with
and it would I assume be some level of a
subjective piece of information as to
what you think is offensive at the
highest order is different perhaps than
what I think or exactly what some of
these other people yeah it creates
terrible incentives and it would
basically lead to an institutionalized
hecklers veto so it's really not tenable
yeah so on that on the hate speech front
which was clear what the Supreme Court
has said about hate speech you're
allowed to do it with with these
exceptions that you've just laid out
you're allowed to say mean things what I
what I'm realizing on college campuses
is they really don't like that the
people the set of people that we're
talking but they really don't like that
so like they think if you like
you it's just the fact you are allowed
to say bad things you can say I hate all
the Jews you can say I hate all the
black people and all the gays or
whatever you can say it you can't cause
direct call to violence but what I think
they think is that if you keep saying
those things I hate these people that
it's going to incite violence now my
counter-argument would be no you have to
use free speech to counter those bad
ideas that's the whole purpose of free
speech but do you see that that that
seems to be the slope that they
consistently are on that if we allow you
to say I hate these people which is
bigoted and prejudiced and all of those
things but it's afforded to us by the
Bill of Rights they think that that's
going to get you to violence how do you
combat that notion if you agree with the
premise well that is something that we
tend to hear a lot in the First
Amendment world and you know first of
all generally speaking in this country
we punish the people who do the bad acts
if I watch your show and I get some
kooky idea and go off and you know
commit some crime we're not going to
throw you in jail because I'm an idiot
and took a terrible idea that you didn't
even intend me to take right now it
might be different though if I was up
here saying you should violently attack
these people etc right exactly and
that's why the incitement standard is so
high he has to be likely to incite and
intended to incite immediate criminal
action so if I tell you hey you know it
would be fun to burn down a building but
you're not likely to do it you're gonna
take it as a joke I probably haven't you
know committed any kind of you know
unlawful expression if I know you're a
pyromaniac and I say hey Dave let's go
burn down a building I might you know
find myself in a very different
situation I think sort of left that
phase at about eight years old but
alright but you know I think that if you
take a look one of my colleagues
actually wrote a piece for a quill that
not so long ago about the Rwandan
genocide and looking over the claims
that the radio broadcasts actually you
know caused more violence and what it
turns out is that the radio broadcasts
first of all only incited people
who were already predisposed and who
already felt that way and it made it
marginally easier for them to find
people and you know be taught how to do
certain things but it was relatively
ineffective as it turns out in
convincing people who weren't already in
a murderous rage to go out and commit
violence and so you know I think that
the fear that allowing these views to be
aired is going to indisputably cause
actual violence is somewhat overblown
now there's a second part to it which is
that people expressing these views might
lead to more people adopting those views
and having prejudiced views is that
possible absolutely right so that's the
part I was revered but that's kind of
the point is that we put those views out
there so we can fight them mm-hmm if we
don't have them in public and we can't
fight them they're still gonna spread
nothing no idea ever went away because
we said you can't say that it just
doesn't work like that yeah how does the
hecklers veto fit into all of this
because one of the things that I again
see on college campuses is when heckler
starts screaming at you and you say just
a second you know if I'll get to your
question or calm down or whatever you
might say they'll say well I have a
right to free speech too as they try to
flip it on you to make you look like a
hypocrite that actually kind of kind of
gets me but I will give them a little
bit of credit I think you say a
university event and somebody comes in
and they chant for 30 seconds or they
stand up and turn their backs and that's
the extent of it I think that we should
protect that technically are they
causing a disruption
yes but it's minimal and it's actually
maximized the amount of free speech
there's to be some room for very minimal
disruption yeah but when it gets to the
point where they are substantially
interfering with the speaker's ability
to get their message across or the
audience's ability to hear them
through repeated shouting or noisemakers
or you know standing in the front and
blocking everyone's views and things
like that obviously that's a problem and
last year we just saw a rash of the
hecklers vetoes going on and it kind of
all started with Berkley and Miley
innopolis yeah when they protesters were
successful in shutting down the event
through of what had before that been
unfathomable on a college campus for an
invited speaker we've seen invited
speaker controversies since fire was
found in basically he never ever am i
aware of any incident that came close to
something like that it was just madness
yeah and they got away with it the so
few arrests were made and I can't help
but wonder if the students out at
Middlebury College where Charles Murray
was speaking seized on that and looked
at the Berkeley students and said well
they were successful in stopping that
event with speech that we also de tested
and they got away with it so let's try
that it's a viable tactic this might be
a solution for keeping this speech we
disagree with off campus and ideas like
that that the tactics that students are
able to successfully utilize they will
behavior that is rewarded essentially is
going to be repeated yeah and I see that
all over the place right now so for
example just a couple months after Milo
went to Berkeley and that happen Ben
Shapiro spoke there and it was largely
nonviolent but it cost the university
six hundred thousand dollars to make
that happen I mean I think an ATM was
broken and a couple windows and that's
it
but that's part of the tactic is if we
can keep ramping this up we'll keep
pushing the security cost and as I said
they had to move my event to a freakin
hockey theater that hockey arena that
couldn't have been cheap and and several
other than these I saw I'm sure you're
familiar of the case of Lindsey Shepard
up at Wilfrid Laurier in Canada
and she just had to crowdfund I think
around six grand to get security for one
of her events so that almost seems like
the new tactic it's almost like we don't
have to we can scare them with some
threats of violence and some other stuff
and then we'll cause the security costs
to be so high that you guys will just
give up well and that's another problem
we've been fighting since even before
all this came to a head is colleges and
universities trying to charge student
groups security fees for the speaker's
based on the anticipated protest or
controversy and that's plainly
unconstitutional it has been for a long
time since the Supreme Court said that a
listeners reaction is not a Content
neutral basis for regulation and you
cannot charge more for controversial
speakers because they might drop
protests that places a price tag on
expression and prices like you said
it'll price the controversial expression
out of the marketplace they're not going
to be able to afford it what student
group has 17,000 dollars to spend on
security
none of them yeah and you know what it
comes down to his administrators the
university itself has to be the
guarantor of last resort when it comes
to the speaker's ability to speak and
this is the business they are in and
sometimes it's unpleasant and sometimes
it costs a whole lot of money but if
you're not going to have a campus where
we can discuss things and we can debate
things even if it gets loud and
boisterous and raucous and contentious
which is everything free speech should
be yeah if your campus isn't going to be
a place where that occurs then what are
you what are you doing so I do want to
make a point of saying that some of the
campuses are getting it right and I'm
sure you know some of the campuses that
are doing a little better than some of
the others but for example at the
beginning of September 2017 I spoke at
Claremont McKenna at there they're doing
a big free speech push because of what
happened the semester before with
Heather McDonald and all hell broke
loose in on the campus and I was
completely welcome there and they even
some of the students who disagreed with
me I mean they asked healthy questions
and all of that good stuff so it's where
I
think it's worth mentioning that some
schools are doing their best to manage
some of this absolutely and on two
levels I think you know first of all
fire rates policies at schools we rate
over 400 different colleges and
universities on our red light yellow
light green light level red light being
you have policies that are clearly and
substantially unconstitutional yellow
light being you have policies that are
susceptible to being applied in bad ways
and green light schools where none of
their policies poses a serious threat to
free speech in the past couple years the
number of green light schools that we
have has nearly doubled which is
tremendous now still close to 60% of
schools have a yellow light so there's
work to be done but you combine that
with the 38 schools that have now put
out statements expressly committing
themselves to free speech something that
you know the University of Chicago
kicked off a while back there's reasons
to be hopeful and we work regularly with
administrators who are happy to have us
you know consult on their policies and
say you know here are the changes we
would make and we're we have amicable
relationships with so many
administrators which is really
gratifying but on the student side also
part of it is overblown I think by media
there are a lot of students out there
who do get it yeah and people of all
ideologies and all political you know
sides there are a lot of students out
there who get it I speak to them on a
daily basis and I there is a lot of
reason to have hope yes it's not a lost
cause no I agree I think it's important
talking about it because even again at
that university everything I
seventy-five percent of the crowd at
least was there respectfully decently to
hear ideas and do that what I felt was
important after and why I still want to
talk about and have you here and all
that is because I want people to be
armed with the right arguments so that
when these this set of people even if
it's just a smaller set that's just
really loud so as a disproportionate
amount of influence I want people to
understand there are tactics you can use
to fight it so I'm curious on that list
of 38 schools that's kind of doing it
right
right now when they've instituted some
of these policies and I remember
University of Chicago did it about a
year ago is there evidence that things
actually get better because I'm gonna
guess that when you give some rules some
of these students they don't want to be
kicked out of school and they might
actually behave better well so I think
you know this there's a lot of
conversation right now about some
legislation even that's going on about
disrupting speeches and mandatory
punishments for students who do so a
certain number of times and you know I
think that's actually less important and
I actually have somewhat of a problem
with laws that create mandatory
punishments for vaguely defined terms
like disrupt which you know could be
applied to pretty much anything that
sneeze you know it's um but I think more
important is when an administration is
saying hey these are the values that
really that this is the wellspring of
intellectual vitality that our
institution relies on mm-hmm these are
the the ideals you should be paying
attention to this is what's gonna make
your experience really worthwhile I
think students will listen to that
instead of maintaining the policies that
say thou shalt not say mean things about
your classmates that gets students in a
very different mindset when they come to
college right what what are the
statements or what are the principles
that you have you guys want to see in
those statement I the principles are
just largely this is a place of debate
this is a place of intellectual
exploration it is not our job as
administrators or as faculty members to
silence ideas that we find controversial
or protect you from them it is our job
it is our you know mission to expose you
even to ideas that you might disagree
with and give you the tools that you
need to analyze them think critically
about them formulate your own ideas and
participate in the conversation because
that's what you're gonna have to do when
you leave after four or however many
years you're here that's part of life in
our democracy is participation if you
don't participate then
you know there's the saying goes if you
don't participate you have no grounds to
complain we have to you know really get
students in the mindset that these are
important life skills and they're
important even in other instances in the
workplace they can be important if you
have a policy position if you're working
at a company that you think is either
bad or is one that you want to promote
you have to be able to think about the
people who disagree with you and what
they're going to say anticipate their
response and formulate an argument that
resolves it you know there's countless
situations in the world outside of
college where being able to think
critically is incredibly important and
really I think that you get a lot of
value out of doing that outside of the
classroom because it teaches you how to
contextualize the skill it teaches you
how to apply it not just in the I read
this assignment let's talk about it kind
of way cuz that's really not how life
works once you graduate I wish it was it
would make things a whole lot simpler
that you'd be out of a job probably
that's true I would have to find
something else to do
[Music]